welcome back to the morning toast it is
your host claudia with a c and i'm very
excited to be sitting down with a highly
requested guest someone who i've
actually never met until today sophia
with an f hi sophia how are you
um i do hi claudia thank you so much for
that intro of course um it's sophia with
an f it's pronounced sofia however i did
have a therapist one time um
write like reach out to me or had her
assistant reach out to me and the letter
was addressed to phofia f-o-p-h-i-a
after i said it's sophie with enough
which is shocking when you announced
your podcast i think people were like
quaking ready to hear what your name was
going to be and i like the name like i
get it obviously because the traditional
way is phia
but a lot of the feedback was fofia and
i want to know what you have to say to
the critics
um i think if you were to look at
where the ph came from the f is like the
original standard
way to spell it and the ph like the ph
doesn't [ __ ] make sense i'm sorry
i mean maybe in the u.s it does but like
outside we're international girls we're
international and like you know we have
we can think outside the box yeah we can
mm-hmm so you're in new york thank you
for coming to the studio i'm very
excited to meet you and podcast with you
i know i feel like we're vibing already
this studio is so cute thank you and i'm
just thinking about my little studio in
my mom's basement right now and i'm
[ __ ] pissed so you are in utah right
you fled in new york and you never came
back never and you're back now and what
are you thinking like what are you
thinking for your life
like where do you want to be because you
really like left new york in a tizzy i
would have done the exact same yeah um
and you've been and being with family is
the best yeah i ended up staying in new
york way i mean excuse me in utah way
longer than i anticipated and i've had
so many people ask me like why that is i
really don't know i think it was just a
mix of
fleeing and needing to be with family
and then covid right and then
i think once i was starting to get ready
to come back to new york i was
also trying to launch my show and my
business and my merch line and all of
those things and building a team and
they're based out of utah and there were
like a lot of different factors however
i am 100 ready to come back now
i was actually looking for apartments
the other day which is a full-time job
and the worst thing ever
so
i mean once i get when i get one see
people are like why don't you just go
back to new york it's like have you ever
tried to get a [ __ ] apartment you try
yeah it's impossible you don't just like
go back to new york do you have any sort
of like ptsd when you come back here
zero oh good which i find really
interesting i have zero of it if
anything i think i feel better when i'm
here that's good i guess because i used
to call it home yeah you know and you
just feel like more in the action yeah
and i i yeah it actually makes me feel
better and i i think it makes me
feel like oh i'm not running away from
something right the way the way probably
utah makes me feel yeah because
sometimes when i'm there i'm like you
know what's so funny
so
when i got canceled majorly in 2018 i
went to utah
shut up yes my whole family we just
[ __ ] threw our [ __ ] in a suitcase and
ran we rented a house and it was so nice
to be like unplugged out of nature all
that [ __ ] and so did you wait that is so
i just put that together there he is yes
how long were you in utah for what felt
like an eternity but i think it was
probably two or three weeks okay yeah
and like were you on social media or
anything like that i was trying really
hard not to i was on way less but i'm a
curious person i just wanted to see what
people were saying about me and it
wasn't good
claudia we have so many stories we could
tell about like our counseling no i know
and so my first question for you was
really like how are you doing because
like i joke now about cancer culture
like when i went through it like it was
so tough mentally like my mental health
was in such a bad position and it took
so long for it to bounce back so my
first question for you was like really
how are you doing
so
how long has it been since that happened
like two years since
made it fly right by yeah um so i would
say i'm in you know a 90 better place
but i would be lying if i would sit here
and say like i'm 100
back to who i was completely i mean
quote unquote normal
for me
um i still like it still shows up in
various ways just kind of anxious
so sometimes i'll like overthink what
i'm gonna say because i'm like so scared
of getting canceled again
do you have that
yeah obviously and you know what as
someone who's a little further out than
you i do want to let you know like it
never goes away oh great
but it does get better and in the end
like you're gonna see it and you might
even be in this place already where when
it was happening you're like oh this is
the worst thing that could ever happen
to me like what the [ __ ] is going on but
then years later you really realize the
value that came out of it like for me i
there were so many people in my life who
were like so fraudulent and like weren't
here for me and they they cut me out i
was like you know what you did me such a
blessing because i'd never want to be
your friend if i was going through a
hard time and you just bounced yep i
grew up a lot like how old were you when
the whole thing happened um i'm 29 now
so i was about 26 27. i was 23 and like
it i just wasn't prepared you know right
so it helped me grow up a lot there are
good things and also it helped me take
control of my business financially i was
much better off afterwards but there are
good things that come out of it yeah and
so you're so you haven't
come fully out of it yet no there's true
you never will though there's trauma
yeah it's like it's just a part of who
you are now right
right um i i think that's true i think
it's one of those things that like i can
heal from it but there will always be it
will always be like a part in part of my
story yeah um i guess the difference is
like when i got canceled it was because
like people were mad at me for things
that i had said like i in their eyes
like i made a mistake um but i don't
really see your situation was so crazy
right because
whether people agreed with how you
handled the situation you didn't do
anything wrong you didn't like hurt
anyone you weren't you were just making
a decision for your business and for
yourself that you thought was best right
so then you know your relationship and
yourself and your business was like sort
of attacked for that when you didn't
actually do anything wrong yeah i think
yeah i think our um cancellations were
different i think mine had like this
layer of serious betrayal
um because you didn't really have any of
that no no with your sister i betrayed
myself yeah
so i think like yeah the betrayal i
think
um i mean
the bullying which i'm sure you endured
but i think maybe like i entered it more
a little bit more you know what you were
so unlucky
the timing of cancellations are so
interesting depending on the news cycle
what's going on not only was it covid so
people were bored to tears
but there was also not much else going
on in the news so i remember everyone
like it's not normal for most news
stories about like two podcast hosts to
get that much news yes but there was
just nothing else going on and it was
coded and sensitivities were heightened
and it was like the timing for you just
was atrocious
really i never [ __ ] thought about
that but it was actually the worst
possible time the new york times was
writing about it like why is the new
york times writing about this [ __ ] no
exactly because it was really not all
else going on and people were working
from home and they were obsessed yeah
yeah
i yeah so i think
the cancellation it was hard that way
and then it was also hard to see
something you worked on for so [ __ ]
long
um be sold for that amount of money that
you knew it was worth i mean i actually
think if i would have stayed on the show
and we would have not betrayed each
other we would have kept working on it i
think we could have sold it for more
right honestly yeah and that was always
the goal because you guys were magic
together that's why yeah that was
unprecedented podcast success yeah from
the first year that you guys did it
nobody gets to the top of the charts
every episode right with a one-year-old
podcast and i think that's where the
disconnect was between me and hers like
you know i was like no i'm thinking a
hundred million she whatever
um but
i think that
seeing it be sold for
even 60 million
that's that's kind of crazy and i've
talked to people about that and they'll
say
that's just how life is like you miss
out on money all the time and you know
these business ventures or you pull out
stock and like you don't end up making a
hundred million dollars whatever
it's very different when you're on a
show
and like exploiting your personal life
your sex life your jokes your humor your
relationship
your relationship for
over two years and then for that to be
sold for that amount of money and like
not see a penny you know that's like
yeah that's very different than like oh
i'm going to pull out of you know
incredible or beyond me right and now it
just went huge you know which i did do
that by the way you did yeah i was like
an early investor and then i took all my
money out and i was like oh i shouldn't
have a big mistake huge
big mistake
well look at me i'm just [ __ ] up my
money
i just think you should not start sofia
with an f for financial assessment like
you should not be giving people
financial advice
absolutely not
okay so now when you look back on the
whole thing like how do you in one word
like how do you feel about the whole
situation now
um
in one word
i get two i don't know why i'm putting
limitations i'm like a sentence a
paragraph i don't care um i would say i
feel
not 100 healed
but i
really feel it in my bones that this is
going to end up being one of the best
things that could have ever happened to
me i agree and even though i'm not there
yet i'm well on my way and like i
genuinely believe that so i know the
answer to this question but i would be
remiss devastated and heartbroken the
people listening would kill me what are
the odds the chances for any sort of
reunion between you and alex zero
that's what i thought but yeah i just
want to put it out there for everyone i
mean
and that she wants to you know venmo me
three million dollars
which by the way
people say it was 60 was more like 40.
oh is that true and then oh and then i
guess she's splitting at 50 50. so it's
more like 20. splitting it with who bar
stool
right yeah they split it 50 50. from
spotify deal
i didn't know that i thought it was just
the merch no that was from my research
no that was in the deal interesting yeah
so 20 so if she wants to venmo me 10
after taxes
lawyer commission oh we're at three
oh my god i feel way better about it all
right
um okay i want to stop talking about the
caller data stuff but i do have one more
thing to say okay go ahead
there was an episode lizzie just told me
thank you
alex said she has a two
um hour recording
of you guys like a conversation that she
really wants to release just so she can
clear her name as you know not the one
who betrayed the other one what do you
say when did she say that i think she
said it on
jackie schamel's podcast love jackie
shimmel oh when was that when was that
lizzie
like somewhat recently oh it was
recently yeah um
i know exactly what phone calls she's
talking about it would 100
not uh cover her in terms of betrayal
whatsoever
and i actually remember the phone call
and this is when i knew she was a really
a scary person to call a best friend i
knew she was recording the whole time oh
the way she was talking
being super careful saying certain words
i'm like [ __ ]
you don't talk like this i know this
[ __ ] is being recorded right right right
so then i acted accordingly oh smart
okay good so i mean if she wants to
release it's very funny after everything
she's done she would want to like
release something to clear her name like
just move on sorry wait actually two
more questions about this because
honestly i'm just really curious yeah so
you guys were sharing an apartment at
the time yes how awkward was that and
like how did you guys move out and did
you see each other um it was it wasn't
that awkward because i avoided the
apartment like the plague and i was
staying at my boyfriend at the time's
house
and then at a certain point she ended up
texting me being like i'm fleeing to
pennsylvania to my parents house like i
we i don't think we should be in the
same apartment got it so then you guys
were able to i mean i think i think
there was like one night before she left
for pennsylvania that i think we were
both home and we're both trying to like
talk [ __ ] on each other
and our rooms are like five feet away
from each other then it was like
yeah but for the most part i avoided the
apartment okay and then you took some
time off and one of my favorite things
because you and i have spoken a lot
about this is you really like you were
dead silent yeah and you released like a
couple was it an instagram story
um yes of me talking
no
i i already know no and by the way i
totally understand being like you just
needing to get something out you know
what's hearing freedom like we were like
what is going so sofia we've heard so
much from alex like what's going on with
sophia and you released this like
twisted video it was it was i i remember
i'm like pale
white
like as pale as this wall i'm sitting on
the carpet of my mom's bedroom right i
have been bawling my eyes out for seven
hours
and um
i am like told by like my team you need
to put out a statement yeah now is the
time and i'm like i don't want to i
really don't want to and then and then
i'm sitting there being like i want to
say this this and this and my team is
like so you're not gonna say any of that
you're actually gonna say this script
and you know what's crazy for how shitty
that video was would you believe you i
told you that was like the 99th like try
oh no i believe you by the way and so do
you have time hop
no you don't what is that oh my god
sorry i'm not how old are you 33
i mean sorry i'm sorry 23 is what i
meant to thirty-three
i'm not that much younger than me oh
you're only two years younger yeah okay
so i'll just say i can't keep up with
the time well actually timehop is like
really like an old people oh it is yeah
so it's basically just an app that you
connect like your facebook your twitter
all your social media your photo album
on your phone and they show you what you
were doing this time last year you get
you check it every day so it's like
today last time it's like a very
millennial and a very gen z thing so for
me like i have had my phone for so long
all of my like apology videos like
a couple days a year when i go back in
time it's like oh on this day you were
apologizing and my apology video was
like so ugly and heinous and like i was
so fat at the time like i just want to
die and i had this mole on my face like
i was going to ask if it comes up in
your time hop but no um
i haven't see i mean well it would show
up on my instagram memories right yes it
would i haven't seen it yet but like it
might be coming out i have a reminder of
call her daddy
and bar stool and [ __ ]
every day of course so like i'm kind of
just numb to it i just exit it out and
like go on my merry way so then you
watch sofia with an f i've listened to a
lot of episodes it's so good thank you
so much it's so good and i'm sure it was
so hard because just like everyone was
wanting you to fail but you just came
out guns blazing and you really changed
the type of podcaster that you are yeah
and what i think is so cool about you i
was looking through your podcast
episodes and you have two episodes in a
row one is an episode on mental health
your anxiety is lying to you the podcast
from the next week fingering a lost art
[Laughter]
you just you can do both yeah and why
did you feel the na the need to do a
content shift when you had so much
success with caller daddy being like a
pretty much sex only podcast um
a i got older
b
i went through something very traumatic
and i think mental health became a real
focus for me because i had to
um and c i think that
we were just i think we were limiting
ourselves i mean we're on the call her
daddy show and this was now my chance to
be able to branch into whatever i want
and especially because of the show is
called sofia than f it's like i'm just
going to talk about whatever the [ __ ] i
want mental health sex relationships
what i ate that day you know yeah and i
like i like it i like it too thank you
um and also what i like is
it's really hard to host a podcast by
yourself very i think that i'm the most
talented person in the world and i can
never like i'm so grateful jackie i have
jackie and i'm sure jackie's grateful
she has me um and i know you bring in
some people sometimes but most of the
show is you
how do you do it seriously like step by
step so so when i first launched the
show
excuse me that first episode
i really i had to write a script oh of
course there was no there was just no
way and there was like legal [ __ ] going
on and like there was just no way and so
i kind of kept that format for a while
and then i just found myself
feeling very
not natural boxed in
i couldn't like i wasn't being as funny
as i normally am because you're not off
the cuff you know all those things
so then i started to just be like okay
i'm just going to write down bullet
points of what i want to cover
and just go that way and that's what
i've been doing granted there's a lot
more editing because i'll go off the
ball side wall and like say some things
that are inappropriate and you know
whatever
um but that's kind of how i've done it
um it's somewhat pre-planned in that i i
don't just hop on the mic and go that's
impossible
no no no exactly um i've also though
integrated my cousin
whose name is also alex which is
hilarious i know um and i'll have her
come in a lot as well that's nice yeah
to bounce off of like a jockey and so do
you think when
and if you've moved out of utah like
your content will change at all
um
oh that's a really good question i like
more guests i think yeah i think
absolutely more guess and i think it
will just evolve the way that i'm going
to evolve once i'm back here if that
makes sense you know
just like my best version can i ask you
a question because i feel like you know
every podcaster there's haters whatever
and people who have legitimate critiques
and i think a critique that we get a lot
that i think you get a lot too is people
finding our voices annoying like vocal
fry
we get that all the time and it's like
if i could change it i would sorry i was
born this way like we i don't find yours
annoying at all mine sounds like i'm
like crying
like
like it sounds like i'm whining cr
everything is a question
like i i yeah does that bother you i
mean does it bother me that my voice is
like no that people
like that that critique
i had to get over that within three
months when people say such horrible
things about you when you get canceled
it actually takes a lot to offend you
moving forward
it's so [ __ ] i wish the worst thing
people said about me that was that my
voice was annoying oh me too
that's when you know our cancellations
were so [ __ ] bad is because
that is like that doesn't even affect me
anymore literally you know um what's
your philosophy on because you i feel
like before caller daddy you weren't
super active on social media like the
podcast was your job and now that you're
very much like an entrepreneur and the
podcast is fed by the instagram
followers and you have a whole page for
sophia with an f podcast you post a lot
more and i'm curious what you're cause
i'm very pro this particular topic what
is your philosophy on facetune
oh
i used to be all about that
um
i'm not against it i think it's like so
basically like instagram stories every
single one used to have a [ __ ] filter
on it now i try to never do that
but i think if you want to throw on a
little bit of face tune here and there
who cares who cares who cares honestly i
love it
i'm obsessed i don't think i've ever
posted a photo that wasn't that wasn't
face tuned but that's because
that's because i'm a deeply insecure
person and i own it like my actual
instagram bio is this is a facetune fan
page like i so just know everything
you're seeing i'm giving you the the
precursor disclaimer this isn't real
and i think that's fair i i like to mix
it up and i like to mix it up because of
my insecurities and hear me out i'm
terrified that i'm going to start
showing up places and people are going
to be like that is not what she looks
like you look exactly like you're oh
that's so nice because you do when i
first went out on tour i was like this
is the first time people are seeing me
in person and i had like a whole 30
minutes in the beginning like i know you
guys might not know who i am but like
i'm the girl from instagram like i look
so different and i don't even care at
this point like i literally look exactly
the same so i don't know if you don't
know how to use facebook
i'm telling you nobody on the planet
knows how to use facetune better than me
and okay if there was a competition i
would win okay well you i don't think
you're not taking it way too far can i
ask you a question first of all are you
single
i'm kind of working things out right now
okay because first of all i imagine it's
quite difficult to date when like oh i'm
i see this girl on hand sophia let me
look her up like uh-huh i imagine it's
difficult to decide who to go out on a
date with wait what do you mean by that
like okay let's say you you meet someone
unhinge and you're like hi i'm sophia i
don't know do you use hinge i don't i'm
not on any any dating apps right now
okay let's say okay you got to a bar
okay this is a really handsome rich man
okay and you're like hi i'm sophia two
days ago yeah you put your number in his
phones if you have franklin mm-hmm and
are you thinking at all like is he going
to google me
no
okay i don't mean to put
in your head no no i'm just so insecure
i'm like nobody because i i don't think
what they would be able to google is
like bad enough that like it would make
a dude not want to go on a date and also
we're talking about like men we're
talking about we're talking about human
beings about the penises usually like he
doesn't care what it says about me on
google he cares like what i look like
you know naked yes i mean that's really
what it comes down to so are you
open because you put so much of your
relationship out there the last time is
that something you will never do again
or will do again
i haven't
decided i think that now that i own my
own company it's not as risky to do
something like that it's like you know
what is dave portnoy and barcelona like
come after my boyfriend like okay cool
um but i think i'll be more careful yeah
you know and i will be more careful with
um
but i mean at the same time like i
didn't it wasn't really me who told
anyone anything it was my ex co-host my
ex-best friend right and you were you
weren't publicly saying who he was right
no pseudonym i never said who he was and
i really only revealed details that i
felt that he would be okay with people
knowing she kind of took all of the the
[ __ ] and ran with it and told me that
got it so it's kind of like you know i
think this next time like i would be
open to letting people know do you still
talk to him
yes okay are you guys on good terms yes
we are okay that's nice yes very good
terms um okay so before i wrap up i just
want to say
you've been on quite a journey yes
you've definitely come out on the other
end and i think you've come out now like
with a like i think a lot of your
podcast episodes are surprising i don't
think people would have thought that
this is where you would have ended up
but it's such a
more like mature well-rounded podcast
and you could really tell like you put
your whole ass into it like you really
are out there just like doing fingering
and doing anxiety and mental health and
i just think that's extremely cool
because i think obviously why people
were always so drawn to you it was like
you're super funny and you know you say
crazy sex things that like people are
thinking but never will say out loud and
there's so much respect for that but now
you're also like changing like flipping
the script a little bit yeah and thank
you so much how long has it been now
since your podcast came out um a little
bit over a year i want to say and it's
doing really well
it's doing really really well
um you know sometimes it plays with my
head a little bit because i did come
from the biggest podcast in the world so
that's like another thing that you know
i kind of carry with your friend of
reference yes but however it's doing you
know incredible it's top one percent of
podcasts just like yours and the
reception has been really really
possible really really absolutely this
am i saying that correctly yes the
salute for you the salutes and you know
a lot of the people that used to listen
to the old show yeah call her daddy like
a lot of them are now supposed enough
people yeah because there's a lot of the
same magic
that was there but you're also evolving
which is always good like when you have
when you're on the internet for a long
time like you can't keep doing the same
thing you've got to evolve you've got to
be different grow up mature because your
audience is a lot of them like the same
age as you absolutely you're all growing
up together yep 100
100
um well i love you i'm so you're so
funny i'm so glad to finally have met
you in person you too i like want to
like go out for drinks one night i can
feel something well i told you that
we're going out tonight and maybe you
should move your flight now that we've
connected you see i'm like cool like i
think maybe you should maybe fight just
think about it i will and jackie
is so mad that she's not here she's
literally like she listens to your
podcast all the time i love her so much
and obviously she's so pregnant she just
i can't risk right seeing people
especially someone who's on an airplane
five minutes ago i haven't seen you in
like a month um so i just wanted to
impart to you like she loves you keep
doing the work that you're doing thank
you so much and jackie and i will film
something yeah sure definitely but that
was sophia with an f and claudia with a
c if you want to hear more from sophia
her podcast is available everybody with
a k
no
her podcast is everywhere right spotify
itunes all the places sophia with an f
and then you can follow her on instagram
at sophia franklin yep sophia enough
franco and the y
oh i like that okay i think you should
change your name so maybe without
franklin
to your podcast oh you should yeah that
will really confuse me like it will be
sophia yanklin
[Laughter]
everyone follow listen subscribe thank
you guys so much i hope you enjoyed this
episode and we're back tomorrow for
another episode goodbye
you